yeah welcome to this video playing Jimmy
jaja I played him before the session
session and then he M had played the
Smith Maura let's see what his coming up
now um I probably won't play the
sicilian play something else but now
it's not playing him right on sending an
odd request but it seems he wants to
play even with um somewhat less time
okay um pan off I play this 294 line
okay it doesn't see doesn't seem to to
have anything prepared or no the line on
e6 how do you answer that or Eve 5mm e6
is enough should be for us really a big
check
wow I am always so amazed how quickly
again some some help how can you commit
the King to e2 in two seconds some
people are really completely cool hmm
it's just like saying okay yeah I'm
losing no matter what yeah it's weird
sometimes I mean that maybe wasn't move
like a 3-yard whatever this is basically
just saying okay I accept that I'm
probably lost lonely questions will you
find the win okay Queen to f6 maybe
taking me true and now first to check
him probably yeah rook e8 on Queen f5
Queen have five marry queen d3m okay now
get ahead rookie age should be should be
also came
well not sure what what is Earth just
Quinby six-year and and then what
exactly
hmm never look the eight next smooth
like resign the advert a disaster yeah
I'm sorry if I'm sometimes a bit too
Frank but how how can you play f3 in
like eight seconds you obviously see
that at this moment ok something went
wrong I think Fisher before him to bit
of a problem maybe think of it a three
or whatever Queen d2 the computer
suggestion but this is just them just
asking for it more than that Kareem a
five is even better according to the
comp but ok it's a disaster you cannot
play with a keen on each one the opening
so minus eight but the comp now ok but
thanks for watching